frédéric et pierre qui sont dans le
public frédéric et pierre ce que vous
pouvez vous lever merci frédéric et
pierre vous êtes à la voix vous êtes
trois donc voilà frédéric pierre et
miley alors vous êtes potes tous les
deux frédéric et pierre alors qu'est
alors frédéric c'est qui frédéric merci
merci d'être là prenait le micro et
frédéric et vous est pote avec donc
pierre et vous êtes tous les deux avec
miley c'est ça c'est ça ouais donc vous
à pratiquer ce qu'on appelle le
polyamour vous étiez potes avant tout
les deux tous les trois vous étiez potes
on sait on s'est connu à peu près en
même temps et on a rencontré on a
rencontré pierre mallet - en fait on est
ensemble depuis 13 ans d'accord on a
rencontré pierre dans une soirée entre
amis c'est pas juste on n'est pas juste
un trio il ya on a d'autres relations
aussi d'accord à huy alors donc mais si
l'on vous vivez tous les trois ensemble
non non on vit pas tous les trois
ensemble donc moi je suis ami avec
pierre parce que c'est quelqu'un que
j'apprécie aussi c'est ça en fait c'est
un peu comme les amis de nos amis sont
souvent nos amis on a un peu et même les
mêmes valeurs on a un peu les mêmes
centres d'intérêt etc
donc quand miley apprécié une personne
souvent c'est une personne que
j'apprécie aussi parce que sexuellement
mais vous ça vous dérange pas que meili
vous êtes amoureux de miley oui et et ça
vous dérange pas qu'elle soit également
avec pierre ça me dérange pas non c'est
vous voulez et en fait c'est alors on a
parlé de tromperie et tout ça la
tromperie ou l'infidélité c'est du
mensonge et c'est quelque chose qu'on
n'apprécie pas du tout on essaye d'avoir
des relations éthiques
toutes les personnes sont au courant et
pour moi ça correspond beaucoup plus à
mes valeurs aussi et derrière ça c'est
pas seulement l'idée de coucher à gauche
à droite il ya ça correspond vraiment à
l'aide d'autres choses c'est à dire que
les en fait dans le polyamour il
yal'idée aussi de sortir des normes en
général alors essaie on sort d'une norme
en particulier mais du coup à ce que
vous formez un couple a trois ou est ce
que ma élite et avec
et l'autre séparément tous les chats
alors en fait moi je suis avec frédéric
et aussi avec pierre mais on n'est pas
dans une dynamique de troupes
ok donc c'est à dire vous vous voyez une
fois pied en une fois vous vous faites
des sorties tous les trois ou oui oui
après peut-être pour vous éclairer en
fait
[Musique]
je sens que c'est un peu flou bastos qui
intéresse moi ce que je trouve hyper
intéressant dans votre émission c'est
que vous avez fait appel à nous dans ce
cadre très précis de l'infidélité et de
la fidélité
mais c'est vrai que je trouve ça hyper
pertinent enfin je pense que vous en
pensez mais je trouve ça chouette moi en
tout cas pas ce que serait que dans le
cadre en tout cas du polyamour dire
produire son jeu très spécifique voilà
c'est ça il n'y a pas en fait de notion
d'infidélité
est ce que vous êtes tout à fait est ce
que l'un de vous trois déjà été
infidèles aux deux autres noms là jamais
autant entendu sur un sujet s'il a
[Rires]
l'habitude mais tu lui serait d'ailleurs
une heure du matin là il est à 23h30 la
question c'est ce que l'un de vous trois
déjà été alloués aux autres oui non mais
parce que vous savez pas écoutés ont
expliqué les c'est la cas n'est pas en
fait c'est pas si compliqué en fait
comme je vous disais ce qui est
intéressant là il ya différentes
paradigme en fait parce que dans le
polyamour en fait le consentement et
consuel pardon consensuel d'accord donc
en fait si vous voulez quand j'ai
rencontré pierre
j'étais déjà avec frédéric parce qu'on
est vieux cow-boy alors oui j'avais il
avait dit attendre et moi c'est pas
c'est donc lui le savait qu'on était
ensemble donc peut pas y avoir
d'infidélité ou de trahison mais vous
avez dit à frédéric vous avez dit
frédéric jeu j'ai tu tombe amoureuse de
pierre aussi oui bien sûr et frédéric
que vous a dit quoi c'est génial
oui bah en fait on était déjà tous les
trois pattes en fêtant à la base
moi j'ai des plans d'eau
j'suis pas avec leur femme mais bon
alors alors allez-y foncez frédéric
hervé pierre qui freine à dix et il est
venu me voir à une
un pique nique il m'a dit écoute obama
et lee alain accroche sur toi mais quand
elle est vraiment pas doué au niveau de
la communication
je préfère passer sinon on va prendre
des siècles non ça c'est un âge précis
où je pique nique et est donc ouais et
donc et donc donc toi tu as dit quoi
alors moi je suis vraiment pas d'eau
avec ce genre de choses va donc j'étais
extrêmement mal à l'aise sur ce que je
vais la voir après on va faire une
petite après midi je peux faire du
karaoké de juste comme ça qu'on sait
regarder vraiment l'un l'autre ont fait
écrire les noms sur une feuille des
chansons qu'on voulait chanter on était
vraiment en phase pas un côté l'autre
parce qu'il y avait un malaise
clairement un moment on a fini par en
discuter et puis bon voilà c'est comme
ça qu'on a commencé la rédaction et la
7e route outre la miley juste une petite
question vous vous êtes vous êtes
vraiment amoureuse des deux différemment
ça veut dire quoi non c'est juste je
comprends pas trop la question dans mais
c'est à dire que vous aimez les deux et
met les deux mais l'un et l'autre pour
des choses différentes mais vous les
aimez pareil c'est ça oui enfin en fait
vous savez c'est moi j'aime bien en fait
aussi les définitions d'amitié à meaux
en fait enfin chanson il ya pas mal de
chroniqueurs qui ont parlé il ya
beaucoup de cas par cas en fait oui tous
les individus sont singuliers et en fait
c'est intéressant de savoir quels sont
les définitions de l'amitié de l'amour
pour chaque pièce que si on a un qui met
du coup dans le jardin qui vous demande
de choisir est ce que vous le feriez où
vous dites non c'est comme ça c'est les
deux en fait cela vous savez c'est comme
imaginer là était parallèle un peu
étrange voyez enfin ça a pas vraiment de
sens en fait c'est un fait ça c'est
juste du contexte différent en fait vous
voyez enfin c'était en fait c'est juste
une question d'imagination imaginer un
monde parallèle si vous avez envie je
vois les bogdanoff oui
donc ou en fait la monogamie et
l'exclusivité ne serait pas la norme
d'accord c'est quelles sont les règles
que vous vous êtes fixé les limites à ne
pas acheter des règles est ce que lui il
a le droit d excuse moi d'aller voir
d'autres filles où vous seriez fâché non
non je serai pêche
bref quoi je ne serai pas fâché ah oui
d'eric orie en fait pour mieux
comprendre je pense qu'il faut aussi
situer les choses
l'exclusivité amoureuse exclusivité
romantique c'est quelque chose qui a une
raison historique d'exister pour moi
c'est à dire que il y à la domination
masculine en avait besoin
nous les hommes de savoir qui étaient
nos enfants donc c'est sûr que dans ces
cas là il y avait le besoin de contrôler
la sexualité des femmes chose qui
maintenant on n'a plus besoin de ça
parce qu'avec la avec la pilule ou les
préservatifs
on peut savoir qui sont nos enfants quoi
et c'est aussi une raison de chutes de
filiation c'est aussi une raison de
transmission du patrimoine
ce sont des choses en fait qu'ils n'ont
plus forcément de raison d'exister mais
on continue à perpétuer et les gens se
les gens sont pas au courant forcément
qu'ils ont de plusieurs choix possibles